thank you
everything all right in there trying to
have a private moment my bad
it's not that private though
[Music]
how you doing yeah good yeah yeah
cool cool
just stop right let me ask that's me
I'm gonna meet my ex for the first time
since the breakup and you're still
calling it The Breakup I thought we were
fine we were better than fun we moved in
together but we had Hamilton tickets
this is serious commitment
so what happened she cheated on me with
my best friend
with him oh that hurts a little bit I
mean I got it the arms are nice but why
don't you even talk about are you just
gonna sit there and say that to me well
she said my answer
I went through the same sort of thing
not too long ago she was his life coach
apparently she opened his mind and in
her legs all of her underwear looks like
this seriously you'd have to sew like 15
of these together to get the pants I'm
wearing right now the worst part I left
my favorite record at his place let's go
find a record shop right now and I'll
buy you a new coffee but I don't want
any coffee I want my copy
I'm gonna break in so I must have a
keeper juices go I'll keep them chatting
you look for the key room for a walk
[Music]
what have you done
[Applause]
sometimes you just gotta see what
happens just go where the breeze takes
you
[Applause]
are you sure you're down for this
[Music]
a week ago
give me your phone or anybody now
foreign
[Music]